hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to prison now a girl by the
name of Emily sent me this game and told
me that I absolutely Oh is something
wrong with me I don't know I'm about to
find out told me that I absolutely
needed to play it and not know anything
about it before I go into the game so
from what I saw I was so alone so lost
so from what I saw it looked like a very
pretty artistic game that I have no idea
what it's about because I intentionally
didn't go out and seek out any
information about the game all I saw was
like the screenshot on the main screen
and I can't even do a damn thing with my
hair right now and oh this is not what I
was oh why is my bed out in the middle
of the woods am I even in the middle of
the woods
seems a little bizarre but maybe I'll
just find out more about it later
so I imagined after my first year at
college I met someone someone I could
talk to we became best friends oh no oh
no it's gonna be an emotional game yeah
I'll drink the wine I spent so many
nights alone at home drinking red wine
but now I found someone I feel safe oh
no oh no oh no it's gonna be one of
those games
oh now all the emotions he Jackie and I
often took a walk in the park
Jackie loved hunting rabbits not now fun
emotions ah so anyway we often met at
our regular spot to talk picnic and have
a good time
oh no wait who is Jackie so is is like
some weird love triangle going on here
I've got my chai tea in my American
party Cup that everyone loves okay open
wine more wine and someone likes wine my
favorite red wine we had a lot of things
in common like our love for what red
wine
why don't you mention red wine a little
bit more not a problem at all a
beautiful day I felt so happy but it
didn't last long why why didn't it last
long
what could possibly ruin this day I
don't know what happened oh but somehow
we broke up
that's like something you know alright
anyway oh boy oh boy
so what do I do now do I gotta go back
probably gonna go back oh it's an it's
an emotional exploration game so that's
like just it's a storytelling based game
we spend so much time together but he
was the kind of person that got a lot of
friends and it changed oh wait
but huh are we still talking about
Jackie here who we talked about I felt
neglected and got jealous because he
spent so much time with his other
friends what didn't you just tell me
that you broke up I did what is
happening I'm a little confused
hello the gate is locked I need a key
Oh so are we out of the story now I have
no idea what's going on
why mean I have an understanding what's
going on it's like story telling us
Jackie changed after she got sick oh no
oh no
Jackie's a dog oh no oh she stopped
eating in the vet said it would be best
to put her to sleep
oh no oh oh this must be the key for the
gate after she died I was alone again
oh man oh that's not cool oh man I
actually just found out yesterday that
my dog Charlie died he was 15 years old
so he lived a long great life but it was
like it was really you know sad cuz 15
years is a long time to know a dog and
Charlie was such a good boy I a saluted
myself more and more and I just couldn't
handle any social contact oh no I went
into this I had a sneaking suspicion
that it would be a field Z type game end
of demo and of demo ah you can't do this
to me
oh come on what
no no I'm emotionally devastated could
not remembering that my dog just died Oh
Charlie was such a good boy oh well glad
I ruined everybody's day I'm glad I just
got here long enough to make her who
would make us do why would this be a
demo who would put out a demo of this
sad story and then leave there oh man
come on
you know what no I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna let this you know I'm not gonna
let this episode get me down because you
know even though it reminded me just
yesterday Charlie passed away but you
know I'll tell you some cool stories
about Charlie Charlie was like the
greatest dog he was a Japanese chin it
was an adorable little puppy schnell and
he was like the coolest coolest dog ever
and it's such a weird coincidence that I
played a game that had a dog that died
in it and then the demo ended like what
the hell and it was a little bizarre to
me but still like you know he was the
coolest dog because when he was winning
this young man Charlie Charlie was a
humper Charlie humped everything Charlie
could not stop humping everything
Charlie just like was unrelenting he was
a tiny dog he weighed like 12 pounds but
he didn't care what it was could have
been like a great mastiff a great day
and he wanted to hump it he wanted to
hump the sides of houses he wanted to
hump besides cars he wanted to hump
everything in existence until eventually
we got him fixed and he kind of slowed
down on the humping but he was still a
little hump monster and so he was just
he was always so much bigger than his
stature was especially when he was young
and I remember way back when Leahy we
were driving out to Indiana because we
always go out to Indiana to set off
fireworks and what was really cool about
this is so far back in the woods that no
one even cared what we did back there
you know there was no one around no one
for miles it was just total isolation
and it was really fun so we would go out
there but Charlie being the like
rambunctious little dog that he was he
was too excited he couldn't like
down a gravel path going like 10 miles
an hour down the road and he knew what
was up cuz it was like the third or
fourth year that were going Charlie's
delay I can't wait I can't wait for
anything I got a guy I gotta go now and
he jumps out of the window of the car
and then hits the ground and that does
that roll thing and we're like Oh
charlie is he dead and then he rolls and
rolls and rolls and immediately gets up
and then Sprint's down the road just
back back black didn't hurt me I'm
invisible black black and then he'd run
down there and he starts he would do
this thing where if he got too excited
he would just run in circles over and
over again and then when he got down
there he'd run around the campfire just
blue and then you know every time we
gave him a bath he did the same thing
you were just like sprint down to the
written down the hallway and then
running circles in and start rubbing his
face on the ground not not like a dog
rub his bond there guys we just rub
face-first
Brad you're running in circles it was a
funniest dog so yeah does Charlie
Charlie is a good boy Charlie was such a
good boy and I miss Charlie and you know
he he passed on but we knew we knew he
was old in his health was declining and
he was fifteen years old so he had a
good long life you know he was a good
dog and you know I'll miss him very much
but anyway so hope your day hasn't been
ruined but those are cool stories about
Charlie and I got a lot more with him
Charlie such a good dog but that's just
an overview Charlie was a great dog and
this was a interesting game but hey at
least it sparked an interesting story so
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you for joining me here and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
no but seriously like I really hope you
guys have a good day today I didn't mean
to bring anyone spirits down with this
game or with what my story was talking
about or the fact that my dog passed on
yesterday but you know it's just like
have a good day this that's the long and
the short of it I'm gonna get a haircut
cuz I can't do anything with this what
am i doing okay mmm